يمنيه جديده خرجت الى الدنيا في بورسودان
على هامش الحرب في السودان
افرحت والديها اذ فاجا والدتها المخاض
اثناء انتظار اجلاء لم يكتمل وصلنا هنا
ذهبنا الى نادي المواد السودان للاجراء
فسجلناه والحمد لله في اول يوم ولكن حصل
هناك اختلاف وقاموا بتغيير الجوازات وكذا
فذهبنا الى متى لمراجعه الهدف فزوجتي وضعت
هناك في الميناء جاها الولاد وكان في هناك
سياره اسعاف تبع مستشفى الهيئه الحمد لله
في الاسعاف وسافناها
انتظر اكثر من ثلاثه الاف من الرعايه
اليمنيين قربانيين بورسودان في ظروف
انسانيه صعبه لاجلائهم الى بلادهم اسر
بكاملها وطلاب تركوا دراستهم وهربوا من
اجواء الحرب في السودان نحن واجهنا
وانصدمنا من حكومتنا ومن سفارتنا والاخوه
في السفاره اليمنيه انهم تنصلوا وتخلوا
عنا تخل التام بعد حجز قواتنا جوازاتنا
معهم لمده اسبوع كامل ونحن مؤمنين في هذا
الاجلاء لكن نتفاجى يوم امس الصباح انهم
اعادوا لنا جوازاتنا
وتخلوا عن هذه المسؤوليه بشكل كامل
داخل المدرسه الهنديه بمدينه بورسودان
ينتظر مئات من الرعايه الهنود والبنغال
عمليه اجلائهم تبدو بطيئه بينما تتزايد
اعدادهم دون معرفه موعد الابحار
يعني ناس كله تعبان مويه ما في
كهرباء عشان كذا هنا
[موسيقى]
ناس كثير كويس
عالقونا قرب ميناء بورسودان اعدادهم
متزايده
الدول العربيه كافه جميع الدول الاوروبيه
منظمات اليو ان اي انسان قادر اقدم اي
خدمه لموضوع واحد اجراء السوريين من من
ميناء بورسودان الى الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه بشتى الوسائل كانت برا جوا بحرا
باي طريقه ولو احنا لكم من الشاكرين
السلطات تقول انها ماضيه في اجلاء الاجانب
من البلاد لكنها تتحدث عن تحديات تواجه
العمليه برمتها مع استمرار تدفقاتهم يوميا
على المدينه عمليه اجلاء الاجانب من
السودان مستمره فشملت جنسيات من جميع
قارات العالم تقريبا غير ان رعايه دول
اخرى لم يجدوا من سوى الاكتفاء بمراقبه
الوضع والانتظار لوقت مجهول
اسامه سيد احمد الجزيره بورس السودان